[Music]
[Applause]
he is now a Hall of Famer inducted into
the radio hall of fame class of 2022 is
Christopher Mad Dog Russo mad dog how
are you today good morning Daniel how
are you today Palo okay I'm good
you start on the football first then
we'll talk some baseball
football
help themselves
protecting the quarterback without Maybe
uh over protecting here yeah it's a fine
line
Jerome bogar did a terrible job of
course you know let's face it there was
a rough in the passing roughing the uh a
passive penalty in the Buffalo Baltimore
game on Buffalo's last drive he was the
official there that was a terrible call
that helped the bills kick that
game-winning field goal and there's no
way under any circumstances you can go
along with the coil last night uh
Saturday Sunday afternoon with Granny
Jarrett and then last night's ridiculous
I mean how in the world now the Chiefs
won the other two teams lost the Chiefs
won so you're going to get over it and
plus the Raiders had a weird penalty
which set up the Chiefs on that
touchdown on the last in the fourth
quarter on that hold off the field goal
attempt so I mean maybe it even doubts
but it's ridiculous Dan I mean I mean
what did you want Chris Jones to do I
mean and that was I don't understand so
I understand you got to protect the
quarterbacks nobody wants to see Skylar
Thompson play for Miami nobody wants to
see these backups around the league I
get that they look at Carolina they're
unwatchable no quarterback you need the
quarterbacks but there's a very a fine
line there where protection overcomes
Integrity you got to let the defensive
lineman you know part of the game is I'm
getting hit a little bit and if they get
hurt they get hurt and in all three
sequences in the last two weeks the
officials the referee made a terrible
call and last night tobacco you can't
support it it's a terrible call plus it
changed because that was a turnover for
crying out loud so the the roughing that
quarterback penalties have been a real
it's a this it's an early season dilemma
for the league
um you know like the flags were with the
defensive holding there they had that
couple of years ago every single play
was a defensive hold it will sort of
sort itself out but it's been a major
problem and I understand the
quarterback's the most important without
the quarterback the game stink I get
that but you have to let the defensive
guys play the game a little bit Yeah I
also wondered you know with the NBA we
knew there was favoritism every time
Jordan went down the lane it felt like
unless it's against the Piston
somebody's going to get called for a
foul you know became business for the
NBA baseball certain pitchers got
certain calls hitters got certain calls
we don't normally talk about favoritism
in the NFL that are there certain
quarterbacks certain players who are
going to get certain calls
how much does favoritism play a role in
the NFL well Josh Allen and Brady I
think your argument is well is is is
well intended I'm not sure if Derek Carr
gets that benefit of the doubt you know
Brady gets to then benefit the doubt and
you touch Brady it's a penalty he's 45
years of age seven super bowls he's an
all-time he's the greatest player of all
time so if he gets pounded you're going
to be in a situation where you know
they're going to look very carefully at
that so yes I agree on Brady Alan same
scenario I think there's something to
that Bogart deserves he deserves to
write an apology to both the Ravens and
the Falcons for his horrendous
officiating in those scenarios as far as
that Jeffers is a good official I mean
he tried to explain it body weight and
all that nonsense despite the fact that
Jones put his arm down I think there's
always that favorites is the mangle but
it's hard to believe Dana Derek Carr is
going to get the benefit of the doubt
because of what he has done in the
league compared to Brady so so I think
it works in both scenarios the first two
I'm not sure it works last night and
again I thought that was a pretty
dubious call on a field goal on the hold
which set up the Chiefs on that last
touchdown so maybe that kind of evens
out and Kansas City won the game anyway
despite the Jones uh penalty the other
two I mean the Falcons have had the ball
I mean the the the bills would have been
in third down territory at Midfield if
not for that left in the pastor so those
two were more
helped decide the outcome of the game
and that's when you get in trouble those
penalties are you it's 15 yards there's
a big penalties and Aikman made a good
point last night Dan although it would
take forever and you'd have it checked
every time maybe go to instant replay
and erupting the pencil maybe you do
that yeah I asked Eli about that last
hour and he said yeah he'd be in favor
of that we're talking to uh Chris Mad
Dog Russo you got baseball Phillies
Braves Mariners Astros Guardians Yankees
Padres Dodgers before we get to that
the way the Mets season ended you win
101 games felt like and you know the New
York media the New York Market it was
like they were just begging for the Mets
to be you know
worthy of all of this what happens in
the off season to the Mets with this I
have an owner who's going to
I I don't know
nuts I don't buy it
you know would you pay the ground 45
million dollars a year he'd probably do
it he's got the highest payroll in the
league uh I think the first thing I'll
talk about with the match the Mets are
going to try to convince you now front
office wise between now and spring
training that you know hey I had a bad
couple days but we won 101 games a great
year you don't win 101 games the San
Francisco Giants in two thousand won 100
ball games and got murdered by the Mets
in the first round and Bobby Jones threw
a one-hitter at him nobody in game four
nobody in America remembers the Giants
for winning 100 games all they ever got
mocked for is that Bobby Jones threw a
one-hitter at him the Mets got one hit
on Sunday night and they blew they
couldn't win a game in Atlanta they did
not play well in September and then at
the Padres walk in there and win two out
of three and buck did a bad job with the
rotation the glom should have gone game
one not sure sir why Diaz is not in
there on the top of the eighth Inning on
Sunday start at the ending instead of
Michael Gibbons the game was probably
over anyway but the Astro the Padres got
two extra runs that Mets had a horrific
finish the year they were now team and
you know I was thinking about this the
other day Dan you know sure there's a
mercenary you know he goes to the
highest bidder his booze I've been at
that you've been at that Stadium forever
New York the booing that he got on
Friday night is one of the is I can't
think of a New York athlete who got
booed as badly as he did in that
sequence why he pitched 145 Innings
that's it he won 11 games he killed him
in Atlanta and then he killed him in
game one I mean you know so I mean it
sure is going to get destroyed like that
and he's not doesn't have any met
credibility because he didn't do
anything for the Mets the grandma want
to Cy Young and her Rookie of the Year
wanna pennant he's gonna get the benefit
of the doubt uh this is an awful finish
plus it was a bad look for the Mets with
the Joe Musgrove thing uh the on you
know late Sunday and you had Brian
Kinney on who is a host on MLB and he's
he called him out and said he that
Musgrove was cheating yeah he did and I
he did it yesterday with me yeah here's
the thing I would say if you're gonna do
that if you're Buck why don't you do it
in a second inning he did it in the top
of the seventh inning a bottom of the
seventh down four nothing the series was
already gone where was he where was he
in his second inning and number two if
you do that then you better be right if
you were going to call out a pitcher who
is a good pitcher he's got a good ERA
just on 100 million dollar contract and
good reputation if you're gonna call him
out in that situation you must be right
and buck was wrong based on what the
umpires did so from that perspective I
lost a lottery the Mets came across as a
rinky dink organization there and I
don't care what anybody tells you Dan
you've been you're the great Sports guy
you can't win 101 games below the
division because you can't win a game in
Atlanta last week of the year and then
get molded home by San Diego and
somebody had a good year and sports
doesn't work that way not New York if
you're the Kansas City Royals I'll let
you get away with it either the Oakland
A's all right we'll give you a break not
if you're the New York Mets with a 273
million dollar payroll all right
handicapped the playoffs here what
should we be keeping an eye on the the
favorites and then maybe a sleeper
the sleepers Seattle
I think Seattle Danny is very dangerous
they were 29 and 39. they remind me a
little bit of the Nationals two three
years ago who were 19 and 31 and won it
all they've never won they make they
they finally make the playoffs after 19
years
great Series against Toronto down 8-1
they can pitch they got a good Bullpen
uh they know Houston I'd be very worried
about Seattle they'd be my Dark Horse uh
logic would tell you Astros and Braves I
think the Braves are the best team
I don't think the Braves have a weakness
I heard you with the Harold Reynolds
thing Dodger pitching worries me they
don't have a closer Braves are very
comfortable playing them that would be
shock Braves Dodgers and then Houston
coming out of the American League best
record they kill the Yankees but I got a
funny feeling Seattle is going to do
something and I'll take Atlanta to come
out of the NL so I'll go Atlanta Seattle
I know it's a wow what the heck wow I'll
go Atlanta I'll go Atlanta Seattle right
now are we past hating the Astros now
that's a good question
I think people like Dusty
I think people respect Verlander
so I think that you know he came back
out of Tommy John he should win a Cy
Young who doesn't like Dusty Baker so I
do think there's a little bit of that
where we are past it it has been a while
they've been a two World Series since
they cheated in 17. so yes they won 106
games you know they won 106 games I mean
everybody's quietly quietly
106 ball games that's a hell of a they
won seven more games than the Yankees
did and I'll tell you right now anybody
tells you differently
coal should not be pitching game one
tonight because the best Yankee pitcher
is Cortez it's not cold but they gave
him 34 million dollars they paid them
for you and they got to pitch him in
game one they really shouldn't be doing
that uh I would love to take the
Guardians Danny but they can't hit so
I'll go Yankees in four I'll go Seattle
and five I'll take the Braves in four
and I think the Dodgers will sweep well
they'll not take Atlanta and Seattle in
the World Series
Aaron judge future how much do you think
it's attached to how far the Yankees go
in the postseason I I don't none I think
the Yankees will and I guess you can
make the argument the Yankees win the
World Series they don't feel as the need
but I would be really surprised if he
doesn't stay here and if you're a judge
Danny why would you leave
the Yankees give you a chance to win
every year he goes to the Giants the
Giants are beating their heads against
the wall with the Dodgers and the Giants
don't win they win one and they stink
and they win if judge wants to be in the
penta race every year he's got this is
the best place to be the Dodgers aren't
going to sign him the Astros aren't
going to sign him he's not going to go
to the Red Sox he's not going to the
Mets so it's Giants of cubs why would
you go to the Giants I don't understand
it and the giant says we'll give him a
fortune but he if he wants to win every
year you stay put I don't know if he'll
get every nickel from the Yankees but
I'd be surprised at the end of the day
if he doesn't stay there I'll leave you
with this I'll give you Albert Pujols's
career or Ken Griffey Jr's career that's
a good question
Pujols made a mistake going to the
angels Griffeys should never have wanted
to be traded to Cincinnati but 700 home
runs and 700 home runs a great finish he
won some championships Griffey didn't
poulos
Griffey is sort of like Iverson I think
he was cool to younger kids that's a
very good point yeah and and Iverson
didn't win I mean he got to an NBA
Finals but you know Junior was always
there was something about him whereas
Pujols you know you just plugged in his
numbers it'd be 45 homeruns you know 325
batting average and a hundred and you
know 35 RBIs you know he didn't vary too
much it was just like he was like Hank
Aaron you know Hank you know just like
oh Hank hit 47 this year that was it I
think Pujols was so steadily great that
we sort of don't those first 10 years
Chris oh he's as good as anybody yes
yeah I mean he might be I mean listen
you got Jimmy Fox uh you know a
Greenberg in his prime this is going way
way back now Paul's might be one of the
greatest it's probably one of the top
three four greatest right hand hitters
of all time I mean think about it I mean
a guy and then he finishes up his career
tremendously with the second half for St
Louis he won the two titles he had a
great finish with the swan song He's got
700 and was it two three home runs
um I he should never have gone to the
angels that was a disaster but I would
say pools is you're right grippy's great
moment Danny is almost the idea that he
scored the game-winning run and the
Edgar Martinez double and he was
rounding the bases in the uh against the
Yankees and I was in a first round
playoff series he never played in the
World Series game so I would say Pujols
big picture better career than than
Griffey and remember
they were an out away against Texas in
that World Series in 11 and he got up
there in that ninth inning and he
released a double in the left center
field everybody remembers Berkman
everybody remembers freeze Pujols got a
huge hit in that 19 against Texas which
helped them win a championship in game
six let's not forget that too guys an
incredible player let's be honest
incredible player great to talk to you
as always Chris you're the best thank
you buddy you know that thank you ma'am
uh Hall of Famer Chris Mad Dog Russo
SiriusXM also MLB and uh Mad Dog he's
he's on with Stephen A Smith on
Wednesdays there on the mothership first
take but uh Mad Dog radio